hey guys and welcome to episode 4 of
grizzly Valley today I decided to make a
main street's
which was pretty much an idea that I
came out of a whim and the same actually
goes for the idea to have a Main Street
in this park as well but I think it's
good for a couple of reasons
just to give it a try for one because
it's a really nice way to make an
entrance part of the park it's also a
really cool way to get good practice and
making buildings because you can
basically just make one string of
buildings in one go
but most of all I think it's really
interesting to try just because it's a
completely different style from anything
I've seen so far in planet coaster and
at the same time it will also be a bit
of a stretch since there aren't really
any pieces to make what I am trying to
go for I'm basically trying to make
something which is very disney-esque so
really some Victorian Main Street like
architecture very much inspired by the
Queen Anne and Second Empire
architecture in America but it's
something which obviously the game isn't
made for at all and uses completely
different objects than what we currently
have so in the end I'm not quite sure
how well it actually came out in the end
and how much it actually resembles
Disney because it barely does so in the
end but I am somewhat happy with how it
came out and you'll probably just see
that by that time anyway it will be
pretty similar to the Disney main
streets in basic set up like I said
before so this is one of those corner
buildings which I wanted to really place
a lot of emphasis on and make sure that
I was actually happy with how this
building looked since it's really going
to be one of these sort of do or
buildings that really greet you to the
rest of the park so obviously I want to
make the corner buildings the ones with
the most recognizable shape but also
with the most intricate details and
really want to make sure that I bring
out the best in the buildings on the
corners here because they're so
prominent on the Main Street as well and
this building is also quite inspired by
many of the corner buildings that you
see in Disney like Casey's corner but I
obviously did have to compromise on many
things there aren't really any good
Victorian pillars so these little
chimney things will just have to do
and another really big issue is actually
the lack of spires Main streets have
many different spires with all sorts of
small details on them but there are no
actual spires in the game yet which is
why I really figured the next best thing
was to place this roof just a little bit
higher than the rest of the building and
have it in I doubt you know way so that
it still sort of looks like a spire and
especially from the front still has the
general makeup of one but it's really
just an inclined gable roof and that's
pretty much how I wanted to do this and
now this building isn't too interesting
in terms of what I try to do in terms of
detail but I will try to do some other
things with the other buildings because
one of the reasons why I also really
figured it would be nice to try out of
Main Street is also so that with every
single building you build you try
different sets of details and try
different styles just to sort of get an
idea of what you can do and what the
different directions are that you can go
into and while I didn't do too much new
things in the first building that is
aside from the chimneys which actually
work really well as dormers which
something interesting to note is I
really think they work surprisingly well
as dormice and barely even looked like
chimneys but it's purely down to context
which is a pretty important point to
always keep in mind like these chimneys
are lined up exactly with the rest of
the windows and really sunken into the
roof quite a bit so that the the holes
in the chimneys are more like windows
and you don't see the holes on the sides
of them and in this context they kind of
look like dolmas because of that but if
I were to actually use chimneys as
chimneys in that case would have
definitely rotated them and placed them
a bit higher on the roof to give them
more of a context that they're actually
achieve me so yeah it's really context
dependent what type of thing you use
different pieces for now the second
building over here is really quite
simple didn't do too much with that
though one really cool thing to try is
to use the very small corner blocks for
the pillars or horizontal white beams as
little corner stones on the side of the
building which actually quite happy
about as well and I also wanted to try
the blue
that building but I will actually return
to that because I think the blue is
awfully blue and there are already more
than enough blue accents in the main
streets so actually want to get to use
signs in the end to see if I can get a
different wall texture on that now this
building over here is basically built to
try out some ideas with a Roman ish
pediment it's a really simple building
with the exception of the pediment it's
really one of those buildings where the
building itself doesn't have a lot of
detail but there's a pediment on top of
it which is where most of detail and
small shapes and stuff like that are so
it's a pretty simple building but it
really sort of just takes its whole
shape and look from the pediment which
is on top of it which is really a
mixture of some different pieces to make
the triangular pediment on top and for
the fries and architraves
underneath it just some random
horizontal beams and actually a
balustrade which came out surprisingly
well I also have to say that the
balustrade are absolutely amazing or the
balconies are absolutely amazing as
ballast rates if you sink them into the
the same placement as the walls are and
make sure that they're lined up in such
a way that you don't get glittering
posts then the balconies can actually be
really excellent balustrade and like
over here was actually a quick thing I
wanted to try is to mix these low fences
or the fence gap like it's a doorway
fence I think with the regular fence
just to be able to get some different
shapes into the fences because it's a
very modern looking fence and I was
really thinking while modern fence isn't
going to work too well with the colonial
or more Victorian like buildings so
really wanted to see if I could get some
more details in there which I suppose
it's actually quite a fun way to try and
get the little doorways in there to get
more details into the fences and some
different shapes rather than just having
a simple straightforward fence and this
building over here on the corner is very
much like the other corner building one
building which I really wanted to focus
on and really wanted to make sure that I
got a look which I wanted in it and so
it's also going to be like a little bit
more special you could
the buildings on the corners I really
wanted to make sure that they had some
sort of thing on it that would draw
attention like a spider or a small Tower
in the front of it or extra layers of
detail or some balustrade balconies in
the front whereas the buildings which
are in the middle of the streets which
aren't quite as visible are really just
more simple buildings and for this one I
wanted to try and get a small roof
sticking out it isn't really much like a
spider or separate Tower but just
something which draws out the building a
little bit more and makes it more
interesting to look at than just one
flat wall with nothing attached to it
really I would have really liked to just
place a Yai roof on it with an ace shape
which points toward the front but there
is no way I can do that with the current
pieces so wanted to sort of compromise
with the curved roof over there speaking
of which and I'm not sure if I'm going
to do this in the future but quite some
people so far I've actually tried the
curved roof to make some Asian style
architecture
which i think is actually a really cool
idea and I might want to try that in the
future so may well get into a Japanese
point of this Park but yeah that's for
sometime later that is definitely not
the case yet and the rest of this
building is really just quite similar as
the building the corner building in the
front of the park since I wanted to make
them sort of visually similar and in a
way that they are both connected to each
other and make the entire Main Street
one more connected Pole speaking of
which yeah all of these buildings I sort
of say that they're separate buildings
but these are really just facades as
very common in Main streets these aren't
separate buildings but it's all just one
building which pretends to be one
building or different buildings by
having the different facades and
different material uses on every part of
the facade but in reality this is just
going to be one pretty large building
and that's really everything that is
behind that
now in a pretty important points that I
also did come back to a little bit in
this episode but I'll look at a lot more
in the next episode is that I really
want to start combining the windows in
different ways like upside down and
different placements and right next to
each other just to make sure that there
are different ways of making windows
because I definitely think there's a lot
of potential to be had there and I
really want to avoid all the windows
looking exactly the same which is just
about here in the video is where I sort
of started noticing all of the windows
being very visually similar in the
entire main streets and when it comes to
the foliage here you could see me sort
of struggling with that I really wasn't
sure if I wanted to have trees in the
middle of the main streets I really
wants to have them but the three-star
currently in the game is just a little
bit too large and they not only really
obstructs a bit too much of the
buildings but also clip into them and
make this main street feel a bit more
closed but then the issue without them
is that most main streets do have two
trees on them and without any trees at
all it's not going to look very lively
so that's a bit of an issue
now over here I wanted to have a pretty
simple fountain looking back at it it's
maybe a bit too simple it's more like a
pillar fountain but I didn't do much
else with it I might want to still get
back to it and add some detail on the
sides but it's something which I'm still
not sure if I really want to do it
because most of the details that we can
add to the sides or ships or other
things which would break the theme that
I have in this area but yeah I just
wanted to have a simple pillar over here
and instead of having a sculpture on top
of it which would sort of break the
theme as well really figured the next
best thing would be to have lights on it
and decorate the area around it a little
bit with foliage now something that I
should come back to because it's sort of
like the elephant in the room in this
video is that I did skip a part of the
time lapse in here namely nearly an hour
I think or maybe even more of trying to
get the paths to actually be in the
exact position and way that I wanted
them to be I tried to actually put it in
there as well but making the paths was
just it
bleep pain and just trying to get
everything to do what I wanted to quite
sometime and why I'm pretty happy with
the outcome it was an hour of pure
struggles and pain and I didn't think
anybody deserves to really see that but
yeah this was basically outcome I didn't
do much else but I really just tried to
get the path layouts which I want it
here which I'm quite happy about in the
end especially the way with in which the
sidewalk the texture sort of works with
the red streets texture I actually think
it came out surprisingly good now in
this corner and I just wanted to have a
quick filler billing almost it isn't
going to be too much really anything
special just something to make sure that
this building on the corner here doesn't
just stand on its own completely which
would be pretty awkward but this will be
the last building of this facade over
here and next to this I would like to
have some foliage and a larger
ornamental building to stand on its own
which you'll see in a little bit but
this building much like the other ones
in the middle of the Main Street is more
or less just filler nothing too
interesting I just sort of took the
opportunity to try some different styles
and try different variations of the
pieces together and also maybe some
different mixes like slightly sinking
some pieces into other pieces and see
what you can make with them but aside
from that it's nothing really
spectacular just a rather standard Main
Street type building something which I
should say though in gaad's do that's
especially that building which I just
built and a couple of them in the main
streets I am saying that it's very
Victorian Disney inspired but I also
took some inspiration from Fantasy
Island and Europa Park as well and there
is also a fair bit of European
influences definitely in the buildings
which partly of course due to this at
switch they're met with but also in the
overall style in which they're made so
it's sort of a Miss mishmash at this
points between different styles and just
trying to get whatever I sort of like in
terms of looks in the main street
now this building over here which I
think in the end manic will be my
favorite building of the main street so
far it's going to be a neoclassical
States building much like a city hall
for instance or a court which is I think
that I am quite happy about basically
because it sort of shows how well the
Roman theme could potentially work out
and it's also one of the reasons why I
think I may want to try Roman theme at
some point in the future in this park as
well because it's something that I did
try as a prototype before try to make
some Roman temples and see how well it
could actually work I would but I didn't
try it in this particular context like
in this case I of course don't want it
to look entirely Roman and wanted to
give it a bit more of a colonial style
and more like courthouses and city halls
in the u.s. actually look so there's a
lot more white of course over here as
well and generally more modern details
and in the end flights as well
definitely but I'm actually quite happy
with how it turned out and it's one of
my favourite things so far and
definitely a theme which is very
feasible in this game so that's really
one of the reasons why I think it's
interesting not just because I sort of
like the building that came out of it
but also because I think this is a theme
where a lot of potential lies not just
in this park but in the game in general
and not just right now with pieces we
have but definitely in the future as
well but yeah anyway this building is
basically just very much like a Roman
temple in basic structure some pillars
there's a stairs in the front but only
in the front and a basic frieze
architrave and pediments on top of the
pillars which pretty much acts as some
very fancy and layers of detailing and
then a roof on top and I kind of want to
mess with details in the pediment as
well which you'll see in a little bit
and it's also relatively easy to make
once you actually sort of know what to
use for everything it's really just
basic white pillars and white walls and
you don't really need to step too much
out of the grid for it though I did have
to make some separate buildings just for
the stairs at the bottom because they're
all layers of roofs
different buildings and aside from that
you sort of just dress it up with
details which you can pretty much do
with whatever but at the most basic
level classical buildings have two
layers of roof plates and a bottom one
and a top one which both have their own
decorations and I wanted to sort of try
this same kind of thing over here as
well excuse me if my knowledge of
classical buildings isn't entirely up to
standards anymore though it's been a
long time since high school classes but
that's basically what I wanted to try in
here and really figure the balustrade
would work best as the top layer and
then on top of that you have the roof
with the pediment in the front which is
this triangular thing which is often
very decorated so I've wanted to try
that over here as well just by having a
little mishmash of different pieces over
here which I figured we'd have the right
texture and some nice detail in there to
make that shape happen and that's
eventually how I did all of it and then
of course I wanted to use the pillars or
I wanted to use the chimneys as both the
basis and the tops of pillars which is
in no way like actual classical tops and
bottom basis of pillars are so that is
definitely something which I really hope
to have some future updates about but a
overall shape and sense of how it looks
especially when viewed from a distance I
think is quite realistic anyway that's
about it for the time lapse flight for
today but I still had recorded a quick
real-time part so let's skip to that for
a second
this is what it looks like at the moment
I actually spent over half an hour in
the end filling with details that I just
wanted to add here and there and seeing
what would actually work I added the
small bell tower over here on this
building just to make it look a little
bit more like an American state building
rather than the Roman temple that it was
sort of looking like before though I do
have to say I think the Roman theme
works out surprisingly well and by
changing some of these things I might
actually be able to get a Roman theme in
somewhere in the rest of the park but
that's really just an idea I still have
to play with and for the rest of the
main streets I just decided to add what
I usually like to call the signs of life
so some lanterns flags hanging just
around everywhere because Main streets
really like their flags and also some
signs like Keith beef belief over here
which actually isn't connected to the
parts because I don't quite like the
peeps walking through the sidewalks over
here which is like a raised step which
wouldn't really look too great so it's
religious there to look pretty I guess
let me actually unpause the game that
might be a little bit nicer and on this
building I actually put the cosmic cow
in rather than just keeping it empty
mostly because I figured I wouldn't want
to keep the entire Main Street empty and
at least have some services which people
can actually go to and I really figured
the cosmic cow was really cute and
wanted to have that in here but what's
actually more interesting about this
building and this is probably something
which other people have used already but
I haven't seen it too much is I actually
took some signs to recolor the building
I wasn't quite happy with how dark the
in-game generic blue walls are and tried
to find some ways to sort of get rid of
that and I think this sign over here is
actually this very long sign so there is
a problem with it
like I voted at this one to just place
it in there and get a slightly different
color but yeah it's two tiles wide and
one tile high so while it's very useful
this building sort of sticks out from
the rest of the buildings but yeah that
doesn't mean that's there's this one
little border in the middle which I
can't do anything about so it's not
really symmetrical so I might want to
get back to that maybe cover this up
with a post or something like that and
sort of did whoops
sort of did the same thing
at the bottom floor where I think I used
this one just to have a slightly
different color which I kind of do like
and even though this building isn't
really my favourites it still was nice
to actually play around with the signs
and I should probably do that a little
bit more in the future because one of my
biggest issues is still definitely that
the Main Street is very blue and there
are pretty much all the colors that the
buildings have are going to be blue or
just one of the more generic white beige
or brown colors and this building over
here isn't really anything special just
sort of filler more or less though I was
really really happy with how the cornice
turned out over here I mean get rid of
that lantern
we're not Michael Bay because actually
it's like a layering of different parts
of cornices and balcony but I'm actually
quite happy about how they turned how to
work together I wasn't quite sure if
they would really work together to quite
make that large corners look that I was
hoping it would give but it's sort of
better than I actually expected so I
might want to use that a little bit more
in the future as well this building here
is just filler because sometimes you
need filler and sometimes you need to
walk through walls as well and this
building is the corner building which
really the only function it has is what
it probably does best and fill up a
corner because in general the main
streets are really the corner buildings
are going to be the buildings which you
mostly will focus on anyway so I really
wanted to make sure that those were the
prettiest buildings with the most
detailed pieces but also different
colors and pieces there the same goes
for this building really and yeah that's
the entire main street or at least half
of it that is there are definitely still
things that I want to change like the
paths are really empty over here and I
might want to add more details to the
buildings especially this one looks like
it could use some more detail around
here especially when you compare it to
the rest of the building with rest of
the buildings which I gradually detailed
a little bit more and in general I could
still work on the Main Street I think
but yeah that's probably also best to
sort of save for next episode or next
episodes because I will try to see if I
can finish the main streets in the next
episode
but I probably can't so I might also
turn it into a third episode but I may
also just finish parts of the Main
Street and move on to different parts of
the park really depends on what I just
randomly feel like doing I do have to
say though looking back the paths look a
lot better than I ever expected them to
look like I was really really worrying
that the paths wouldn't look very Main
Street like especially given how that I
still small patches of grass in between
them and I couldn't get this much more
sidewalk looking than it currently does
but it actually really surprised me with
how good the paths actually worked for
this kind of thing and especially for
ground level I think it's quite a Main
Street looking thing and I basically
want to do pretty much the same thing on
the other side very similar buildings
more of the Victorian Queen and style
architecture at least try to sort of
make that look like it it's not going to
be 100% what I'm hoping for in that
regard but I'm still quite happy with
how this turned out so far and hopefully
I'll be able to improve on it in the
future and finish the Main Street so
that's what I'll do next time so thank
you guys for watching this episode and
see you guys later